alors moi je suis très très triste je
trouve que c'est dramatique que ce soit
annulé en revanche je suis pas du tout
surprise je pense que c'est obligé
aujourd'hui avec la pression
malheureusement avec le
cyber-harcèlement avec les menaces
malheureusement il a été obligé
d'annuler il faut rappeler que c'est un
endroit où il y a eu plein de concerts
il y a eu Christophe Willem est-ce que
j'ai entendu ici à l'époque il ne
s'était pas outé il avait pas dit qu'il
était cuire donc évidemment ça ne pose
aucun problème il y a eu un concert de
Richard berger
sur la sexualisation alors sur un
militantisme justement tu viens de le
dire on le savait pas ça nous regardait
pas on a la fiche
c'est un chanteur il a repris à monter
la France à
l'eurovisionnementalité
Claude François quand il a des
Claudettes il fait du buzz aussi
Claude François
homophobe avec les